ah filming hi I'm back and I'm opening
mail surprise surprise what a world this
is um okay so this is gonna be kind of
quick little like I say that for every
video um so let's start okay look at
this all tiny guy it makes me look like
a big big old person this is from
Keighley Carol in Grand Island New York
why does New York name so many islands
we've long island grand island and then
you know other islands that i know of
yet but this is the cutest tiniest
little card oh yo hands high right to
the point i love it and hello grace you
or what you are my favorite youtuber and
i look forward to your videos every day
hope you have a fantastic day katie lee
Carol this is such a wonderful little
card thank you so much for this this is
so sweet of you I hope that you're
having a wonderful day you know because
I'm having a great day and you should
too thank you for that Kayleigh Carol
your name is excessively long let's move
on to Casey Oh your last name is weird
to me hye-rin wait me Q&A wiki where are
you from Canada ah hmm I won't say
anything cool though cool name okay this
is ooh good buying that's my name that's
my name that's my name OMG you are so
freaking awesome i watch who you're
hemin ship is beautiful looks like a
girl handwriting I watch you every
weekday you always make my day when I'm
sad and can always make me smile yeah
don't be sad why you said why a sad
because your last name is crazy okay
it's little bit better you guys change
it but don't I don't like when people
change the names I feel like stay
authentic to you from the girl that
guy's our hair and wears makeup we you
have a great sense of humor and you're
absolutely gorgeous you are absolutely
gorgeous thank you
so much for this letter this is so nice
of you love you grace Helbig loser no
well then just remember stand you been
hey ha oh that's so sweet thank you so
so much ken ad and Cassie yes I like
your first name we'll just work on the
last name ouch my feet is hurting my
English is also hurting okay a kid in
the cornfield from Kansas City huh can't
I just showed you stop showing I will
never learn I will never learn um a kid
in the cornfield you know what I like
corn my body takes a long time to digest
corn but it's delicious whoa there's
something in here what is it you some
meat I pay you sent me maxi pads for a
second no you've sent me born this way
are these tattoo is what i use do they
glow in the dark I should read because
this will grow monster yay oh did he
used to go on shirts why am I not
reading the letter to find all this out
and a Hello Kitty with the lady gaga
glasses on why am I not reading a letter
to figure out what they are okay hey
grace just want to let you know that I
can't move on with my day without
watching your videos oh no don't use me
as a crutch use me as a correct thanks
so much to give us a good work and asked
me like Lady Gaga's a pulse up these
stickers are for you put them anywhere I
hope you know how to apply them I don't
how do you apply it give me one I'm
gonna do one I don't know how to apply
them if they're stickers they just
should the back should come off and then
it should be sticky and then you just
stick it somewhere ah there something's
happening whoo is this the sticker part
yeah I'm gonna put it on my boobs that
seems like the right thing yay born this
way and I put upside down yay I was born
upside down I was I had them Billick
record after on my neck we what's next
Angie thank you for the stickers by the
way that's awesome kid in the cornfield
how's that corn an Jean Madigan yeah
from soy sin city
crazy crazy I like the green I'm really
glad and moments like that them not
colorblind yeah yeah not having defects
okay whoa love is love I like that
that's so cute I'm pretty and gay thanks
okay getting you brother okay which is
cool you mother [ __ ] all right got my
attention I'm listening i'm watching
your mail blog right now and it's so
great I'll remember when you hate me I
don't but great I'm glad it was was it
good for you awesome I'm a lesbian but
if you giggled at that then I'm happy
oconee droopiness and idea dicks are
always funny they're always funny they
look so vulnerable uh buh buh buh okay
well I have to go and I love you and
hope your day's great I hope your day is
great thank you so much and you gave do
something fun with your ribbon you gave
me a rainbow ribbon yay look at all
these people oh I wish I had something I
could I don't have a something to stick
that there but look at you guys are
making me so accessorize I'll put this
on my wrist I'm wasting time in this
vlog by doing something and not reading
the mail letters oh and you're still
watching me do something bellowing oh
look at that like my outfit just Scott
egg that's all right so where is oh ok
this one has thank you very much for
that letter nugget so sweet Mo Vaughn
Edwin's from Little Rock Arkansas go
clean some little round I think whoa
what is in here there's something in
here what the well this is a magnet cool
as a pug let witten the pugs wearing
hair which makes it cool oh so cute cool
let's plug in a rather get it and I'm
what is a bouncy ball and a bit of money
from not hear from Brazil we're still
money we're still money I like this on
that
ever happy zone money i owe grace hey
you a crazy penmanship I got you some
goodies that I know you will like a
bouncy ball magnet for your fridge and
some Brazilian money from a trip I took
this summer best experience of my life
oh I'm glad it was so fun for you thank
you for this letter i'm gonna read it
later because I've been um going slow in
this video you're the best Emma I mean
you are the best thank you so much and
look at his penmanship it's so friday
and he's up in colors oh we're so glad
i'm not color by my sticker fell off oh
oh i don't know how to feel about it
okay I'll go to the side move forward
face when crisis happens you need to be
a pro what would lady gaga oh i don't
know like I don't know Aaron Neil from
Houston Texas whoo I was gonna say your
street name because it's a crazy name
but then I decided that's the wrong
thing to do in these videos just tell
where all these secretive ah look at
this little oh and I shows it anyway so
bad oh so pretty this is like what moms
give these are so pretty let's see whoa
hey grace great show your kind of funny
yeah well I think that's it is this a
horrible letter maybe I'm only
continuing to write so you don't feel
like it was a waste of time to open and
read this because you know I care even
though I even left you a stamp so you
could write back you left me at stamp so
i can write back i'm not gonna write
back I'm sorry I'm really sorry I don't
write back to your letters but I make
these videos so that you feel like
you're being acknowledged and that these
are going to me and not to UM a trash
can but thank you for this this is so
nice why did I draw this stupid pens
without erasers done oh you're getting
so mad at yourself in this letter don't
do that you don't deserve that yeah um
thank you very much for the cider that's
so sweet of you oh yeah postcard oh and
it's from Rochester New York and these
two little girls are coming up out of
the water in Rochester New York hi guys
my name is all
listen and I met you twice before yes
you did and there's pictures to prove it
look at those pictures we met we met we
met we met I wanted to say hi from my
college my roommate allows your videos
thanks for being so awesome I hope
you're having fun in school all right
you didn't get alcohol poison yet to do
great good for you thanks listen I stay
here from yeah oh don't get excited it's
just some ping letter writing but yes
how would that's crazy from someone that
didn't leave their name oh it's so nerve
and it's already open this letters
already open it's confusing to me please
don't let it be terrible Thanks whoa we
got a lot going on here holy mackerel
ways Makka lilies but then the brain
cancer later hi I like you a lot you
were funny alright so i'm bored with
myself so I wrote you woo you have a lot
going on your best button this is so
cool um oh you've heard the word butt
load I liked but load uh at least Dalton
I hope that it few right back you will
happen to be really bored I'm not going
right back to thank you so much good
letter that's so nice of you I'll bet
your boredom subsides and then you find
something really fun to do with your
life good luck thank you for this ladder
that's really awesome of you and if
you're ever bored write more letters
there the fun thing to do it's okay this
is really awesome look at this look at
this crazy stamp and it look who it's
from Babe pimpin pimpin prepare pant
pant pant pant pant pant pant pant pant
Brown yeah that's what I think British
music sounds like this person to look
funny because I made all this joke such
time about um Prince William sending me
mail and then they made it look like
it's my friend I am what is it what is
it with you like it what is it I'm
confused by it already
oh it's a tight letter dear grace I've
been watching your internet show for the
past few months and I would like to
congratulate you on your wonderful humor
and innovative use of this modern media
I would like to say that had I not be
become married to catherine middleton I
would have I cannot read I would most
certainly have loved to spend time with
you if you would consent to do so
nonetheless please let me offer you a
gift of friendship it is a ring which
once belonged to Elizabeth the first
sincerely William oh my god did you put
it what is what get outta here you crazy
little gang in I'm no it's not gonna fit
I got big American fingers okay
everything America's bigger and as are
my fingers but I'll put down my little
pinky so pretty Thank You Prince William
you went all the way this is so
hilarious thank you so much from this
crazy person that did this you are
wonderful and the child in me that still
believes Santa might exist is thinking
that maybe this release myself okay
what's next so we got this thing from
Shannon Brooks from Fort in California
Shannon Brooks you were so pretty like
so pretty you are so pretty like so
pretty are you related to Mel Brooks or
the Brooks Brothers do they make clothes
okay go muscles your muscles give me
much so what is this grace hey girl hey
your videos are awesome and you have to
be the funniest person I've ever seen
you seem like such a fun person
interesting haha well I'm a singer
guitarist and I love music and stuff
someone to make you something hopefully
you like having to do with something
blue moon river wow you made me a mix CD
of random music that's awesome thank you
so much lift this tab pull CD out ah you
made a cool little pocket
or thank you that's awesome i will
listen to this I don't know anything
about music so please lesson me about it
oh my goodness and I will read the rest
of this letter I promise whoa oh and you
have a the mix look at that she made the
playlist oh that's so cool thank you so
so much Shannon Brooks that is so
wonderful ah I feel I feel so good
that's not the part of this this is from
crazy name can't kami core what is that
you tell me what that name is CA o IM h
e and I'm sorry that I can't say your
name properly but you're from Belfast
and Ireland no one may be one crazy name
Irish before you are from Ireland Irish
people wear shamrocks all the time and
you said oh my goodness this is so funny
I'm going to take a shot with this just
so you know it's gonna get used this is
awesome thank you so bad oh my god
Bailey's truffles get out of here get
out of here and then come back and kiss
me in my mouth that is so nice
dailygrace it's a letter it's pink girl
oh man I think of vagina sending love
what grace firstly apologies but the gay
card Oh college is about the gay card oh
it's not that gauge litigate my old
roommate introduce me to your blog and
I'm addicted is this fan mail I'm 26
that means this is weird Cooper month no
I'm 26 now too so it's okay it's like
peers hanging out um oh my gosh I can't
believe you sent me and you sent me the
neck and necklace what is going on you
are crazy you ah ah oh my gosh ah that
is so beautiful holy crap you are so
nice and ah what look it's do I will
untangle this I promise it's
x it's a Pegasus and a flower and a
rainbow oh my gosh this is what gay
dreams are made of it's perfect thank
you so so much from k km aah aah KO me
hat okay you are so nice thank you so
much it's so wonderful oh man I felt
really connected to my heritage now I'm
English Irish and German and that is
just the most wonderful thing okay this
is from um it's from airmail okay let's
find out what's going on in this air
mail go hand kick it open yay okay whoa
whoa radiance by Britney Spears you
serve me little radiance sample okay are
you trying to tell me in sometimes hello
there grace just a small gift to say
thank you for gracing the world with
your crazy antics sean collins AKA
Pictou Sean oh oh you got me lemon
verbena hand cream in this adorable
little bird it's an Albert it's adorable
oh my gosh I've never heard of this
before this is a hand cream it's a hoot
they got me I got me right in there matt
is so awesome thank you so much this is
so cool and I've been thinking that my
hands do not feel wonderful lately and
what's been missing and hollow hand
cream thank you that is so cool oh my
god you guys are the sweetest little pea
chose you guys like Pete Rose that candy
delicious don't knock it till you tried
it oh ok this is from Jack Coonan I know
you you tweet at me and then I see it
and the night remember your name and you
paid for overnight shipping on this
which is amazing that you did that thank
you so so much ok oh it's a letter a
letter inside of a thing you're crazy
you just David Copperfield that ok Oh
in be very careful I like it it's yellow
already appeals to my senses celebrating
your birthday oh you getting a birthday
card cuz the present present in close
card to any bartender for your free
birthday drink what get roo excuse me
may I please have a glass of water enjoy
haha have an amazing birthday jeff
that's so nice thank you and then you
had another letter oh my gosh hey grace
Here I am sitting in my economics class
room studying for the test yet [ __ ]
I will be taking in 24 minutes until i
realized tomorrow's grace's birthday i
need to write a letter and send her a
card you see where the priorities are
here grace I hope you have an amazing
birthday oh this is so so nice I hope to
meet you after one of your shows the pit
when I go to New York City on winter
break perhaps have a great day please do
this is so wonderful thank you so much
that's so powerful you are a wonderful
human being okay um last but not least
this is from Danielle quit dang gone in
Walnut California you know what to do is
just walnuts I didn't realize that they
were a town and you use duct tape good
for you girl good Bert go hands make
things better for you and you like this
song it is an old ha what is in here oh
my goodness oh my goodness what's up i
use these things i like them 3d well
avatar hey grace how are you how do you
like the weather in LA I live in New
York but when I was in LA I love the
weather it's 102 degrees right now Oh
sucks for you I love watching your
videos I can watch your videos under
four hours you were one [ __ ]
hilarious person you are you've got a
little drafty on here the storm'll um I
just finished watching Dance Moms it was
the first time I'd seen it on that show
was funny it was episode where the black
or had to wear an afro I solid episode
racially stirring ok I'm done by next
grace teaches you how to do something
video should teach us how to do the
moonwalk maybe
maybe sincerely Danielle hope you like
them oh no you didn't you are crazy go
you love duct tape so does if it's so
expensive did you realize that when you
were using it that it's really expensive
maybe we'll use it in moderation next
time just kidding so I get aggressive
when I'm opening things what is it but I
know what it is cuz you letter already
said it and I know it and you guys don't
and what could it be and guess what it
is and get in the last chance to get us
chances to guess I look at this
elaborate packages yeah oh my god that
is so cool so cool oh wow this is
awesome thank you so much that's so cool
i will be using these you guys are
enabling me yay i love it thank you guys
so so much for all this mail you were
wonderful little people and probably
some of you are bigger than others but
thank you guys so so much bye